si le Secours populaire permet à de
nombreux enfants du nord de rejoindre
les plages du sud la pédophilie permet à
de nombreux enfants du sud de visiter
les caves du Nord
et maintenant j'accueille Gaspard Proust
pour l'été de Gaspard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un jour
je suis cousin marseillais de prousta
oui monsieur Ardisson c'est Summer et on
s'adapte avait l'accent c'était plus
marrant disponibilité gentillesse
flexibilité mais surtout un esprit
comique affûter de la tête coquillette
aujourd'hui j'aimerais dédicacer ma
rubrique à Marseille la belle rebelle
mondialement connue pour être la plaque
tournante du chômage international
parce que Marseille a beaucoup à
apprendre à la France Marseille c'est tu
me réveilles que de diversité de
différence de non similitudes
d'antithèse de contradiction de
contraste de disparité
disproportionne du semblant de
dissimilitude de distance de distinction
de divergence d'écart d'hétérogénéité
des compatibilité d'inégalités de
nuances de variétés et c'est là où
s'arrête de mon dictionnaire des
synonymes
on détour de ma ville tout est ambiance
des raisons et surprise tiens au débotté
d'une rue qu'est-ce donc que c'est ta
troupement de métro sexuels de
prostituées qui s'ignorent et de
salariés tristes mais bon ça c'est bien
sûr c'est le plateau de Plus belle la
vie
voici donc quelques conseils pour passer
un bel été c'est le thème des noyade
comme vous voyez un homme qui est dans
une piscine ou à la mer et qui crie s'il
vous plaît attention c'est pas forcément
un rhum
ces gens-là n'ont pas le monopole de la
politesse
non peut-être que la personne veut vous
montrer qu'elle aime être regardé quand
elle coule
respecter le dites tu coule c'est cool
[Applaudissements]
il se peut que ce soit c'est rare mais
bon un appel au secours et que vous ne
savez pas nager se pose une question
qu'est-ce que vous foutez à la plage
un tellement que de lucidité sur ses
propres
aptitudes devrait vous faire quitter
immédiatement les lieux faut-il prévenir
les secours bien sûr
sinon comment il s'affûte ces gens-là on
exerce pas la truffe du cochon de
truffier en lui montrant où elle se
trouve
le rôle des secours c'est de deviner ce
qui peut se passer respecter ce travail
mais l'été c'est aussi le soleil on dit
qu'il faut se protéger bonne hiver
Bagatelle billevesée calembourdin le
coccigru fadaise faribole
niaiseries et sornette et c'est là où
s'arrête le mode dictionnaire des
synonymes
autre conseil de vacances
les moustiques problèmes avec les
moustiques c'est qu'ils ne comprennent
pas ce qui est le patron il faut des
représailles mais comme dirait notre
ministre dans la justice la [ __ ] oui
mais dans la justice
[Applaudissements]
tes moustiques que vous attaquent soyez
vigilant soyez à l'écoute chercher à
deviner ces trajectoire compter
mentalement le nombre de ses battements
d'aile pour évaluer le point il va venir
vous piquer et dans combien de temps et
vlan tu l'attrapes immédiatement tu lui
suces le sein qui vient de boire tu dois
crache à la gueule et tu lui dis c'est
pas bien ce que tu as fait
certes la violence ne résout pas tous
les problèmes mais la l'avantage de
diminuer le nombre de personnes qui la
cause
autre message de l'été
les enfants toujours laisser sa
surveillance mais qui gambade les
pauvres couillons qui se perdent qui
prennent la route chez salopiaux là
que le rouvrira les portes d'un salaire
[ __ ] des générations se faire enlever
vers des contrées comme la Belgique oui
si le Secours populaire permet à de
nombreux enfants du nord de rejoindre
les plages du sud la pédophilie permet
de nombreux enfants du sud de visiter
les caves du Nord
mais bien sûr
cela s'appelle la curiosité
intellectuelle
et il vaut mieux commencer
autre petite
chose qui peuvent arriver et mycoses des
plages
faut-il en avoir peur la réponse de
Bernard de la Villardière est très clair
si c'est des mycose de droite ça me
plaît
plus sérieusement non bien sûr faut pas
avoir peur
mais non c'est le début
une mycose c'est quand même la
possibilité d'avoir un animal de
compagnie à faible coût et du fidélité
Somfy mycose au pied tu n'as pas bougé
je pense tong mais on ne dit pas tongs
mais claquettes la tangue fait tongue la
quéquette fait claque
la pétanque
toujours à pratiquer sous un soleil
torride l’éternel problème de la
pétanque le cochonnet à ne pas confondre
avec la boule de geisha la balle de poux
ou sa femme car attention si pierre qui
roule n'amasse pas mousse femme qui
rebondit fini dans les orties
[Applaudissements]
je termine par un petit soldat sondage
d'été il paraît que les françaises
veulent Valls pour une nuit Montebourg
pour les vacances j'ajouterai sa pomme
pour l'éternité
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu